the thing that i notice that happens
more often not at least when guys are
coming to me and i mean i often deal
with some guys that are like weapons
right now like they make seven eight
figures they run multiple businesses and
then they're like yeah but my childhood
was [ __ ] you know i didn't see my dad
or my dad was hit by lightning when i
was young or i was raised by a single
mom sort of thing like that
and
they managed to figure it out at some
point but for the most part these guys
tend to end up being like nice guys you
know they're mostly beta you know
they're uh you know they do the whole
you know be a shoulder to cry on you
know they try to friend zone their way
into a girl's heart sort of thing is
that stuff that you experienced yourself
or
was that something you know that you had
to reconcile to overcome
so i don't i don't remember who
who said it
i know it was somebody with a voice
either in like manosphere version now or
or before or somewhere
but somebody said something to the
effect of
when you when you grow up and you see
women at their worst it becomes very
difficult for you to pedestalize them
and and and be
that god
and
i don't i i don't know what the
experience of all these other guys were
how nice and loving and con their
mothers were i i suspect they were good
solid people because
my mom
was not that person i remind me i got a
lot
i really value
my mom uh i i think
you know
i'm gonna miss her when she's gone
but
we have a good
dialogue now
but that is because when i was from 18
to 23 i didn't talk to her
and and i finally discovered forgiveness
and that place a really big role in my
life because forgiveness made
everyone's life better
not just for my mom to be able to talk
to our child but for me
to tonight carry that poison or place
that blame on somebody else from my
adulthood
when i was 11 this was the formative
moment there were tons of moments before
him but this was the formative moment i
watched my mom get arrested and she
didn't have to get arrested she got
super drunk
uh
not as usual but but it was a fairly
regular occurrence and she got into a
fight with this woman and she went on
the street and fought her i remember
holding her back from the door trying to
hold her back my mom's a big big woman
man like
and and i'm 11 years old swimming work
so she went out there five got arrested
got booked for the night uh
so went to jail i mean my sister you
know living by the stable i showed what
mom is dealing with this cause my dad's
in philly he don't know [ __ ] about this
uh
and at that point i was like
i'm gonna have to figure it i might have
to figure this thing out by
myself and and it was it became very
hard for me after that point
to look at to look at girls as something
better than me you know so so i never
walked around
with with those nice guy tendencies i
think like i know what you're talking
about i see them i never had them
because that [ __ ] never served me um
growing up it hit that it definitely
didn't serve me none of that served me
but the one influence in my life the
main female influence of my life
uh i developed a
a weird kind of disdain for for a while
and you know where that manifesto
because because
no one makes out of childhood unscathed
man we all come out with our issues
i went the other way
and
and that
has its sew of problems it's funny me
and my fiance joke about this all the
time that i was like a straight dog
like like you know you bring a stray dog
in and the old owners used to beat it
and [ __ ] and then feed it and every time
you trying to be nice and pet the dog
the dog snarls at you
that's kind of like that now i'm way
more domesticated and that's a good
thing because she's a very good woman
very patient
in in me figuring out a lot of a lot of
things but
but that
other end is not you know that's the
problem i would imagine and i don't know
if you see this because i never coach
guys uh in this regard
but i've always felt like when you grow
up
being real nice
and you finally get your backbone it's
really easy to go the other way
okay so
my issue
i'm i
i'm naturally still because i kind of
like to be violent and i recognize the
power of that violence so i i will
always avoid violence and plus i try to
think about
the overall how the dynamic
if if we we pop off into a conflict and
ain't even gonna be physical like even
on the internet you see how i am with
people and then the guys we've worked
with some of the uh the spaces we've
intersected i wouldn't say i'm on the
best terms but i'm i don't think i'm a
bad terms in anybody because i recognize
there's there's a price to pay for that
but
in that has not always been the case and
i've had to really work to temper it to
be a
to be even you know wherever you come
from you gotta you gotta balance it out
my issue was being very
self-centered and not thinking about the
things going on around me because if if
i thought about things going on around
me very often at least until i got to
high school uh
you get taken back taken advantage of
are manipulated
and so i developed a way to live out
different than that to this day
emotional monitoring now she's figured
out how to do it because she's smart and
she's a good one but to this day
uh i am i'm like hypersensitive
to anything that
that smells of emotional manipulation
and and probably react
disproportionately
uh to it than i need to but that that's
uh
that that's that's where that that you
know kind of comes from it and or rather
how i responded to not having
um father because because of my mom my
mom's influence was she was a parent
sure but like
it's a lot of things that she got got
very wrong i think but part of being an
adult is you don't blame that [ __ ]
like like how sad would it be if i'd be
sitting here you know in prison or
something and i'm blaming blaming what
happened to me 18 20 years ago i don't
want to downplay the role of your your
you being you know how you were raised
but at some point being an adult by
definition you've got to take
responsibility and i think i've done
that
you